>>> A WHO'S ON FIRST AMONG
HOUSE REPUBLICANS, EXCEPT IT
ISN'T FUNNY BECAUSE OF THE GIANT
ISSUES THE COUNTRY FACES AS
NANCY PELOSI AND DEMOCRATS YIELD
TO THE NEW AND NARROW GOP
MAJORITY.
TODAY KEVIN McCARTHY'S TITLE
REMAINS HOUSE REPUBLICAN LEADER.
BY THIS TIME TOMORROW HIS HOPE
IS TO BE THE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE.
TO WIELD THE GAVEL, TO BE SECOND
IN LINE TO THE PRESIDENCY, BUT
DESPITE YEARS OF PLANNING AND
CAMPAIGNING FOR THIS IT VERY
MOMENT, McCARTHY IS STILL SHORT
VOTES AND EVEN SOME ALLIES SEE
McCARTHY'S MATH PROBLEM AS
GETTING WORSE DESPITE WEEKS AND
WEEKS OF CONCESSIONS TO
REPUBLICAN CRITICS.
SUNDAY, YESTERDAY, McCARTHY MADE
EVEN MORE CONCESSIONS THAT WOULD
WEAKEN THE SPEAKER'S POWERS AND
HE SIGNED THE LETTER DETAILS
THOSE CONCESSIONS THIS WAY.
KEVIN McCARTHY SPEAKER
DESIGNATE.
IMMEDIATE RESPONSE DESCENSION
AND MOCKERY.
NINE REPUBLICANS A MIX OF
INCOMING MEMBERS AND SITTING,
NOT ENOUGH AND MORE THAN NINE
GOP HOLDOUTS AT THIS HOUR.
IF EVERY ELIGIBLE VOTE IS CAST
McCARTHY CAN ONLY AFFORD TO LOSE
FOUR.
YOU GET THE MATH AT HOME.
THE STAKES WILL BE ON THE
OBVIOUS DISARRAY AMONG HOUSE
REPUBLICANS.
CONGRESS REMAINS PARALYZED UNTIL
SOMEONE TAKES THE GAVEL.
UNPRECEDENTED DYSFUNCTION.
FAILURE FOR FIRST TIME IN A
CENTURY AND CRIPPLING
EMBARRASSMENT.
THIS IS BOB GOOD LEADER OF THE
NEVER KEVIN FACTION PUSHING
REPUBLICANS TO THE BREAK.
>> HE'S PART OF THE SWAMP
CARTEL.
I THINK YOU'LL SEE ON THE SECOND
BALLOT INCREASING NUMBER OF
MESHES VOTE FOR WHAT IS A
TRUE -- A TRUE CANDIDATE TO
REPRESENT CONSERVATIVE SENT OF
THE CONFERENCE.
>> STRAIGHT UP TO CAPITOL HILL
AND CNN LAUREN FOX IS THERE.
WOW.
THE MATH PROBLEM FOR KEVIN
McCARTHY.
BETTER?
WORSE?
SAME?
>> Reporter: EXACT SAME PLACE.
IN FACT, JUST GOT OFF THE PHONE
WITH ONE REPUBLICAN, RALPH
NORMAN, WHO TOLD ME HE IS STILL
A NO ON KEVIN McCARTHY.
WAS ONE OF THOSE FIVE NEVER
KEVIN VOTES WHO IS SAYING THIS
MORNING THAT HE STILL HAS NOT
SEEN ENOUGH FROM McCARTHY TO
TURN AROUND AND VOTE FOR HIM
TOMORROW ON THE FLOOR.
THAT LEAVES McCARTHY SHORT THE
VOTES, AND IT LEAVES McCARTHY'S
ALLIES READY FOR A FLOOR FIGHT
COMING AROUND ONCE IN A CENTURY.
LAST TIME SAW MULTIPLE BALLOTS
IN A SPEAKER'S RACE.
AS YOU SAID, MANY THINGS KEVIN
McCARTHY TRIED TO DO OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL WEEKS TO TRY AND
WIN OVER SOME OF THOSE
CONSERVATIVE HOLDOUTS.
SO FAR, NOTHING HE HAS DONE HAS
CHANGED THE ARITHMETIC FOR HIM
TOMORROW.
ONE OF THE THINGS HE TRIED TO
GIVE THEM YESTERDAY, LOWERING
THRESHOLD OF NUMBER OF
REPUBLICANS IT WOULD TAKE TO GO
TO THE FLOOR AND REQUEST A VOTE
TO OUST THE SPEAKER.
THE NUMBER NOW, MAJORITY OF THE
CONFERENCE, BUT HE'S SAYING HE
WOULD BE WILLING TO TAKE IT AS
LOW AS FIVE, JOHN.
STILL WASN'T ENOUGH.
INCLUDING FOR ONE REPUBLICAN
MATT GAETZ ON THE CALL SAYING HE
WAS STILL A NO.
JOHN?
>> FROM CAPITOL HILL.
DRAMATIC 24 HOURS-PLUS AHEAD.
WITH ME IN-STUDIO SHARE
REPORTING MELANIE AND OTHERS.
KEVIN McCARTHY AGREES TO LOWER
THE THRESHOLD REMOVE THE SPEAKER
IN FIVE VOTES.
SAID NO MORE MAGNETOMETERS
OUTSIDE THE HOUSE CHAMBER OR
MASKS AND SECURITY VIOLATIONS.
BILL POSTED 72 HOURS.
EVERYONE TIME TO READ IT.
ANYTHING LEFT TO GIVE?
THE NINE WHO SIGNED THE LETTER,
PLUS THE OTHER FIVE, AT LEAST
14.
CAN ONLY AFFORD TO LOSE FOUR IF
EVERYBODY VOTES.
>> MATH GETTING WORSE, NOT
BETTER.
DESPITE ALL CON SCESSIONS, AND
GIVING AWAY THE STORE, NINE
SAYING NOT YET.
A BIG PROBLEM FOR McCARTHY.
DOESN'T HAVE A LOT LEFT IN HIS
BACK POCKET.
ONE THING POTENTIALLY DO.
LOWER MOTION TO VACANTATE FIVE
TO ONE, CONSERVATIVES SEEKING
INITIALLY.
HE SAID HE DIDN'T WANT TO DO
THAT.
DIDN'T WANT TO PLEDGE AT ALL.
A MASSIVE CONCESSION.
FIVE IS A MASSIVE CONCESSION FOR
HIM AND EVEN THEN NO GUARANTEE
THAT WOULD GET HIM THE VOTES.
IN FACT, LAWMAKERS ON A CALL
YESTERDAY PRESSING HIM.
WILL THIS GET YOU VOTES IF YOU
CAVE?
NO ANSWER.
ASKED MATT GAETZ, DOWN TO ONE,
WOULD YOU VOTE FOR ME.
WOULDN'T GIVE AN ANSWER.
A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY HEADING
INTO TOMORROW.
>> AT SOME POINT IF HE GAINS
SPEAKERSHIP, THOUGH, IT'S LIKE
HE'S SPEAKER IN NAME ONLY.POWER.
NOT THAT THE DEVIL NEEDS
ADVOCATES HERE.
FOR SOMEONE WHO IS AN
INSTITUTION OF WASHINGTON MAKES
SENSE TO FACE SOME SORT OF
CHALLENGE.
RIGHT?
IT SHOULDN'T BE A CORONATION.
BUT I THINK THE PROBLEM FOR HIM,
AND FOR THE CONFERENCE IS LOOK
WHO IS CHALLENGING HIM.
RIGHT?
IT COULD BE A COMPLETELY DE
DEBACLE.
>> SCOTT PERRY, FREEDOM CAUCUS
MEMBERS, NOTHING CHANGES WHEN
NOTHING CHANGES AND THAT STARTS
FROM THE TOP.
MAKE THE CHANGE OR GET OUT OF
THE WAY.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
MY QUESTION.
INSURGENTS AGAINST KEVIN
McCARTHY.
LOOK, HAD TO CONCEDE THE STORE,
STILL LOOKS WEAK.
MORE VOTES THAN ANYBODY ELSE.
WHAT DO THEY WANT?
IS THERE NANYTHING THEY WANT OR
JUST TO THE HUMILIATE KEVIN
McCARTHY?
>> BINGO.
THAT.
SEEING HIM TOO MUCH OF A
CONCILIAT
CONCILIATOR.
AT ONE POINT IN HIS CAREER MANY
YEARS AGO A FAIR
CHARACTERIZATION.
A REPUBLICAN FROM BAKERSFIELD,
CALIFORNIA.
HARD TO BE A REPUBLICAN IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
CAME OUT OF THE LEGISLATIVE
SYSTEM.
COMES FROM A PLACE OF
COMPROMISE.
ACTUALLY MAKES SENSE FOR A HOUSE
SPEAKER.
TO BE IN THAT ROLE, BUT HE
HASN'T BEEN THAT KEVIN McCARTHY
IN MANY, MANY YEARS, BECAUSE AS
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY CHANGED HE
HAS HAD TO CHANGE WITH IT.
I THINK WE'RE AT A REAL -- THIS
IS GOING TO BE A REAL EXERCISE
IN AMERICAN DEMOCRACY HERE.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE SOMETHING
PLAY OUT, UNLESS SOMETHING
CHANGES DRAMATICALLY IN THE NEXT
FEW HOURS THAT HASN'T REALLY
PLAYED OUT SINCE 12923 DURING TE
CIVIL WAR HISTORY.
A FIGHT LIKE THIS HAS GONE
PUBLIC A SMALL GROUP LIKE THIS
FORCED MULTIPLE VOTES, AND THIS
GROUP THAT IS HOLDING TOGETHER
CANNOT GET THEIR OWN GUY.
FOR THEM, KEVIN McCARTHY IS AS
GOOD AS IT GETS.
WHO COULD IT BE IF IT WASN'T
KEVIN McCARTHY?
COULD MAYBE BE STEVE SCALISE,
WHO'S ALSO 57 YEARS OLD.
WHO ALSO COMES FROM A SIMILAR
EXPERIENCE AS KEVIN McCARTHY
DOES POLITICALLY, AND WHO HAS
THE MORAL HIGH GROUND HAVING
BEEN A VICTIM OF A POLITICAL
SHOOTING, DOMESTIC TERRORIST
SHOOTING, DIRECTED AGAINST
REPUBLICANS.
SO HE HAS A CLAIM TO ARGUE FOR
BIPARTISANSHIP AND FOR
COMPROMISE AND EVEN STRONGER
CLAIM THAN KEVIN McCARTHY DOES.
I THOUGHT UP TO THIS MOMENT
KEVIN McCARTHY WOULD GET IT,
BECAUSE NOTHING ELSE MAKES
SENSE.
AT THIS MOMENT, IT MIGHT NOT
HAPPEN.
>> AND SCALISE STANDING BEHIND
McCARTHY ALTHOUGH KNOWS FULL
WELL HE DOESN'T NEED TO SAY
ANYTHING.
HE IS ONE OF THE TWO OR THREE
PEOPLE WHO'S MIGHT EMERGE AND
"THE" MOST LIKELY BECAUSE OF HIS
POSITION AND CREDIBILITY ON BOTH
SIDES, BOTH TO THE RIGHT AND
LEFT IF THERE IS A LEFT IN THE
HOUSE REPUBLICAN CONFERENCE.
AND WORKS FOR PAUL RYAN AND JOHN
BOEHNER.
SELF-SERVING PLAY BY A SMALL
GROUP OF REPUBLICANS THREATENS
TO MAKE A MOCKERY OF THE
INSTITUTION AND FURTHER THAT THE
PARTY IS NOT PREPARED TO LEAD.
THE ADJECTIVE ISN'T DOING THE
SPEAKERSHIP TO ONE OF THEIR OWN
BUT TO WEAKEN McCARTHY.
EMBARRASSMENT MAY BE THE POINT.
THAT'S THE QUESTION.
DO THESE -- WHETHER THERE'S 15,
20, A NUMBER ROUGHLY SOMEWHERE
IN THAT BALLPARK DO THEY HAVE
ANY INTEREST GOVERNING OR
LOOKING TO JUST BE HOUSE OF
PROTEST?
>> THE PLACE THEY'RE IN, THAT
THE HOUSE REPUBLICANS ARE IN,
WHEN YOU LOOK AT LARGER
WASHINGTON, IT IS SORT OF A,
WHEN YOU ARE IN THE EITHER, THE
ONLY ONES WHO HAVE ONE LEVER OF
GOVERNMENT.
THEY DO KIND OF PLAY THAT
OVERSIGHT DURING A WRENCH IN
MODERN POLITICS, IN THE WAY THAT
DEMOCRATS ARE DOING BUSINESS,
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO
LEGISLATE, BECAUSE THEY DON'T
WANT POLICIES THEY DON'T AGREE
WITH BECOMING LAW.
THAT SAID, I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS YOU'RE HEARING FROM
REPUBLICANS LIKE BRENDAN BUCK,
LIKE THOSE WHO MIGHT BE ON THE
OUTSIDE BUT UNDERSTAND HOW THE
INSIDE WORKS, THEY'RE SAYING,
GUYS, LETTING DEMOCRATS --
DEMOCRATS ARE WINNING NOW.
BECAUSE YOU ARE THE ONES WHO ARE
CAUSING SO MUCH EMBARRASSMENT
AND NOT ALLOWING ANYONE TO BE A
STANDARD BEARER.
>> REMARKABLE.
TAKE A STEP BACK.
TODAY SHOULD BE A HOUSE VICTORY.
CLAIMING HOUSE MAJORITY YET
COMPLETELY OVERSHADOWED BY
DRAMA.
>> WHO ARE THEY, WHAT DO THEY
WANT?
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE, BUCK,
REASONABLE, ESTABLISHMENT
CHAMBER CONGRESS-TYPE
REPUBLICAN.
SAP DO THE OPPOSITE, BECAUSE
HE'S ENEMY TO THEM.
AND BOB GOOD, HEARD TOP OF THE
PROGRAM.
CONSERVATIVE FROM VIRGINIA SAID
WE WILL HAVE ANOTHER CANDIDATE.
JUST WAIT.
>> WHO IS THAT NAME?
WE -- HERE WE ARE IN THE 11th
HOUR.
THERE ARE NO NAMES.
GIVE ME A NAME.
BIGGS ISN'T GOING TO WIN.
>> RESIST A FEW MORE HOURS WHAT
I HAVE RESISTED THE LAST SEVERAL
WEEKS, AS YOU KNOW, PUT FORWARD
A NAME THAT PERSON SUFFERS ALL
ATTACKS AND RETALIATION AND --
>> YOU DON'T HAVE A NAME.
WHAT LEADER --
>> YOU'LL SEE THAT NAME TOMORROW
ON THE SECOND BALLOT.
>> WHO IS HE?
IS IT -- COULD YOU ENVISION
STEVE SCALISE FOR MAJORITY
LEADER?
>> FIND OUT TOMORROW ON THE
SECOND BALLOT.
>> A PROMISE SEE IT TOMORROW ON
THE SECOND BALLOT.
I GET AND UNDERSTAND.
DON'T PUT OUT THE NAME TODAY.
HARPOONS FLY.
DO THEY ACTUALLY HAVE SOMEBODY?
IS THERE SOMEBODY?
SCALISE WHISPERING?
A CANDIDATE WHOSE NAME WE DON'T
KNOW?
SOMEBODY WHO SAYS, FIRST I'M FOR
KEVIN.
IF HE FAILS, THEN YOU MAY TURN
TO ME.
>> AS REPORTED AT CNN ASKED A
GROUP OF HARD-LINERS, ASKS STEVE
SCALISE AND JIM JORDAN IF THEY'D
BE WILLING TO RUN.
BOTH SAID NO AS LONG AS KEVIN IS
IN THE RACE.
FAR AS I KNOW, STEVE SCALISE
HASN'T BEEN MAKING MOVES BEHIND
THE SCENES, KNOWS HE CAN'T.
GENERAL WISDOM, IF McCARTHY PUPS
OUT OR SENIOR REPUBLICANS WALK
UP TO HIM AFTER MULTIPLE
BALLOTS, GAVE IT A TRY.
NOT WORKING.
I THINK STEVE SCALISE STEPS UP,
AUTOMATIC FRONT-RUNNER.
A CHAOTIC SITUATION.
OTHERS COULD JUMP IN.
>> ISSUE, SHOULD McCARTHY STEP
ASIDE, RE-DO THE RULES,
RENEGOTIATED BECAUSE REPUBLICANS
WHO ARE MORE MODERATE
REPUBLICANS SAYING THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO SUPPORT RULES THAT
KEVIN McCARTHY NEGOTIATED IF IT
IS NOT HIM.
THIS WILL JUST THROW EVERYTHING
INTO TURMOIL EVEN IF HE DOES
STEP ASIDE.
GOING TO BE QUITE THE SHOW THIS
WEEK.